what do we think of this well two things
the queue right first of all and then
the queue jumpers has become a huge
Scandal
um pretty overblown in my view but the
cue first of all what does it tell you
Tina about Britain when he came back and
saw you've been spending a lot of time
in America in the last few decades when
he saw that cue well what you saw was
that the queue had become it says the
people's own give back to the queen so I
mean person after person said the same
thing after 70 after her giving us 70
years of Duty it was the least I could
do so the queue became this act of of
gift to the queen waiting so I actually
reflected I think and again I wrote this
in my song column I think it reflected
all the virtues of the queen yeah
resilience hard work determination
courage you know humility doing
something for somebody else not yourself
and talking to strangers talking to
strangers and getting on with it
it was it was the personification of all
things which actually made this country
great which I think we should be looking
to get back into oh completely I mean I
joined it I was I was lucky it was only
five and a half hours but you did you
you get to the back of the queue and and
you start talking to people and you
start chatting you make friendships and
it really was it was the Brits lover
Cube but this was the cue of all cues
and I think there was something
just rather rather special about so some
people some very famous people joined
the back of the queue David Beckham
famously joined the back of the queue
and whether you're cynical about his
motivation it went down very well with
people that he didn't take a VIP route
like President Biden and others who of
course weren't able to do that but there
were people like uh Holly Willoughby and
Philip Schofield who front this morning
are the big programs in this country
obviously
um who it took advantage of an
opportunity for journalists I know
Richard your own partner Isabel is
defending herself for doing the same
thing and actually put up a pretty good
defense
um but here they are uh going down what
was a sort of VIP line
adjacent to where the public were going
and of course not having to queue now
all hell broke lies about this they've
been the subject of I think I'm
ridiculously over the top campaign
there's 20 000 people have signed a
petition to have them fight of course
they shouldn't be fired it's ridiculous
it may have been a misjudgment I said
myself on the show I don't think anyone
should have been jumping the queue full
stop wherever you are unless you're a
world leader and you just obviously
there's a Time issue
um they they went on the program this
morning and said this Holly said this on
the program today
the rules were that we would be quickly
escorted around the edges to a platform
at the back in contrast those paying
respects walked along a carpeted area
beside the coffin and were given time to
pause none of the broadcasters and
journalists there took anyone's place in
the queue and no one filed past the
Queen We of course respected those rules
however we realized that it may have
looked like something else and therefore
totally understand the reaction please
know that we would never jump a queue
what are you making I mean full
disclosure I'm a good friend of Hollies
I feel very sorry she's absolutely
distraught I think about the reaction no
well it's true and genuinely there was a
clearly in the head a blurring of the
line about work if you're working and
you're covering it I think a lot of
journalists went through there Isabelle
did I know other journalists who did it
and haven't been subjected to all this
but is it the old-fashioned thing the
British are the best at queuing in the
world right to the point somebody tries
to jump in right well it just also
became like this it grew that feeling as
the days went by you know so suddenly
now it became like at the end it became
like you know cutting a Queue at Mecca
you know because it was so long because
it was so arduous and there were
veterans and 90 year olds and so on
right it was the statement the whole The
Waiting was the statement itself and so
that's why it kind of got as it did but
you know these things kind of take off
as we know you remember during Diana's
funeral when suddenly there was that
whole thing about where's the where's
the flag on top of Buckingham Palace I
was editing the mirror of the time
demanding they lower it that's right and
so things like that they build and they
have to they get very cathartic Richard
I mean Theresa May jumped the queue and
nobody seemed to bat an eyelid um other
politician Angela Rayner I think the
labor Deputy leader she jumped the queue
um you didn't you you queued actually I
queued I was I was your own partnership
you were split down the middle we took a
very different view on it and you know
what was your view my view was I wanted
to join the queue I wanted to to be
there to experience it and to go through
it and you've no idea of frankly whether
it's going to be two hours five hours or
ten hours but I was there and there were
moments where you think wow this is a
real thing and but look I loved it I
don't regret it for a minute and you
know the joys of Technology you could
work a bit on the old smartphone and
whatever that's fine
um so but you know other people took a
different view Holly and and Philip look
in a sense they made a judgment and it's
turned out to be a misjudgment yeah I
don't think they I don't think there's
nothing flogging that's going on I think
it's got a better MPS did not need four
passes maybe one for the other half but
they didn't need four parts yeah I mean
I think they actually it was there have
been some funny memes about this
Domino's Pizzas put out a tweet
so they were going to be delivering
sorry for any apologies for my weight
team but they've just taken an order
from Holly and Phil and actually the
best thing they can probably both do is
just have a laugh about it get on with
it now I don't think anyone the Venom of
social media I've been in the receiving
end you know I used to do a Morning Show
before them
um in the next door Studio I had to
vacate mine for not believing all
princess Pinocchio I mean the world's
gone nuts so I say this end let's end
the petition end the petition um foreign